thirty years ago the Berlin Wall fell
destroying Soviet Communism and
vindicating the conservative Reagan
Revolution but that great victory for
freedom created a big problem for the
conservatives libertarians
traditionalists religious right
everybody who made up the post-war
conservative movement what unites us all
now we will examine the rubble of the
Berlin Wall then Elizabeth Warren picks
up an endorsement from the backbone of
our democracy
she says the good guys get a win in the
war on Christmas and leftists try to
save a convicted murderer and rapist
from execution all that and more on
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Noel's show
[Music]
the Berlin Wall fell down 30 years ago
almost to the day the Berlin Wall
existed stood from 1961 up until
November 9th 1989 so we're a few days
late I've noticed a lot of people
haven't really been commemorating the
fall of the Berlin Wall which was the
most significant moment in most people's
lifetime most people who were alive
today I guess I was alive today but I
was I was still in the womb so according
to the left I wasn't alive I was just
like a completely dead inorganic lump of
cells or something and according to
reality I was alive and it was a very
significant event it was an event that
was inaugurated by Winston Churchill he
announced this metaphorical Iron Curtain
much earlier in 1946 at Westminster
College in Missouri in in America and he
described this Iron Curtain and in this
speech we see the very beginning of what
we would have called the modern
conservative movement international
organization intended to do in the
immediate future
from Stettin in the Baltic to Trieste in
the Adriatic a lot of people when they
think of that speech one of the most
famous speeches of the 20th century they
think of it as referring explicitly to
the Berlin wall caz the Berlin wall was
such an image of communist oppression
but the Berlin wall wasn't built for 15
years until after that speech the Iron
Curtain was this sphere of Soviet
influence actually the phrase Iron
Curtain wasn't Churchill's own phrase he
borrowed it from Joseph Goebbels from
the Nazi Joseph Goebbels who had had I
think was the first person to describe
Soviet influence as an Iron Curtain and
at Churchill picked up on that and of
course it was true and it was very
bizarre for Americans to hear this
because we have been told throughout the
whole war that that the Soviet Union was
our friend uncle Joseph Stalin was our
friend and now we hear that he's in
half the world behind an Iron Curtain
what this did what the Iron Curtain did
the end of the Second World War and the
advance of Soviet Communism was it
forged what would have been called the
conservative movement and we are now in
a moment where we're trying to figure
out what the conservative movement means
it forged what was called fusion ISM
fusion ISM was developed by William F
Buckley Jr at National Review and Frank
Meyer an editor at National Review and
fusion ISM made perfect sense during the
Cold War what fusion ISM did is it
brought together libertarians and
traditionalists and the religious right
and social conservatives brought all
these people together with a common
enemy Soviet Communism now what did the
libertarians have to say about the
Soviet Union libertarians and the
classical liberals hated communism
because it was collectivistic you so you
had this kind of individualist economics
versus collectivist economics then why
would the traditionalists and the
religious right and social conservatives
hate the Soviet Union because the Soviet
Union was atheistic so you had theism
Christian civilization versus the
Atheist
Soviet Union and therefore the
libertarians the economic individualist
and the social conservatives and the
traditionalists come together in this
fusionist
body brought together mostly by Bill
Buckley after the fall of the Berlin
Wall
those groups did not have much in common
what was amazing about the fall of the
Berlin Wall is it basically vindicated
the whole fusionist coalition because it
worked the he defeated the Soviet Union
we had been told since the early 20th
century from the New York Times and the
Evening Post and all these leftists that
the Soviet Union was the future I mean
they they said I've seen the future and
it works that was Lincoln Steffens
the journalist referring to Soviet
Communism and then Bill Buckley famously
said a conservative stands a thort
history yelling stop because you might
have the future you might have seen the
future in the Soviet Union but we're
going to stop it
and it
to justify it I mean the huge advance of
conservatism in America brought to the
pinnacle under Ronald Reagan who was
probably the only man in America who
knew that the Berlin Wall was going to
come a tumbling down
I spoke to Peter Robinson who's the host
of uncommon knowledge on the Hoover
Institution and who wrote the famous
tear down this wall speech and he
constantly refers to Reagan's vision he
knew he had that boldness he said tear
down this wall
mr. Gorbachev because he knew that
communism was doomed and while all the
smart people in suits and ties in
America said we had to come to some sort
of understanding with those slave
masters in the Soviet Union Reagan said
absolutely not and that fusionist
conservative coalition ultimately won I
think it was so Charles Krauthammer who
said the most shocking event of his life
was the fall of the Berlin Wall and it
was shocking to have very many people
but not to Ronald Reagan because he knew
that that thing was going to tumble down
so it vindicated that and yet after the
fall of the Berlin Wall the conservative
coalition had no reason to stay together
anymore which brings us to where we're
going now because we're in a fraught
moment for the conservative worldview
we'll get to that in a second speaking
of fraught moments and dangers let's
thank our friends over at Express VPN
let me give you an idea on how many
people want to steal your data have
vulnerable your data are recently over a
hundred million people had their
personal information stolen in a major
data breach that means social security
numbers means contact info credit scores
all of that more taken from Capital One
customers there is a very good chance
that you were affected by this these
kinds of attacks are getting more
frequent and more severe which is why I
highly recommend and feel so comfortable
using expressvpn you can't control how
big corporations are going to mishandled
your data but you can protect yourself
as a work it's very simple expressvpn is
an app for your computer and phone that
encrypts and secures your data if a
breach can happen to Capital One it can
happen to you okay I know you think that
you're immune because you know you took
an HTML class in the 90s but you're not
okay if they can get into Capital One
they can
- your computer - I would say never ever
ever go online without expressvpn that's
if you care about your privacy in your
[ __ ] safety ok expressvpn connects with
just one click it's very very fast it
cost less than seven bucks a month which
is nothing expressvpn is the number one
rated VPN provider by TechRadar seen at
the verge countless others if you are
listening to this program
chances are you check out some pretty
weird stuff on the Internet alright
talking about that incognito window some
pretty weird stuff
turn down the blinds lower the lights go
to daily wire comm if you know what I
mean so you don't want that data to get
out it could be very embarrassing at
work I mean you could really have some
some serious consequences use my special
link expressvpn comm slash michael mi CH
AE l right now you can arm yourself with
an extra three months of expressvpn for
free support the show protect yourself
Express VPN comm / Michael mi CH AE l
for an extra three months free so the
Berlin Wall Falls great victory of
conservatism and now the question is
what does it mean to be a conservative
fusion ISM is not coming back
the buckley coalition is not coming back
not because of any problem with bill
buckley the guy is one of the greatest
men in recent American history it's not
coming back because communism is no
longer seen to pose an existential
threat I mean you see this all around
you anecdotally and you see it in polls
there was a poll from the victims of
communism Memorial Foundation as a
pretty recent poll showed that communism
is viewed favorably by more than 1 in 3
Millennials and Millennials are people
now who were late 20s early 30s how
about the younger generation only 57% of
Gen Z that's the generation after us and
only 62 percent of Millennials believe
that China is a communist country and
not a democratic country so it seems to
be getting worse you know I mean a lot
of the Zoomers a lot of Gen Z when I go
to my speeches and they're great they
give me great hope for America but
those are just the ones that show up and
tune into conservative speeches on
college campuses the majority of them
the trend is not looking great now if
you've got these kind of numbers I mean
even if you look at still with
Millennials fifty-seven percent of
Millennials believe that the Declaration
of Independence guarantees freedom and
equality better than the Communist
Manifesto does fifty-seven percent
what's that say about the other forty
three percent not great that's compared
94 percent of the World War two
generation believes that the Declaration
of Independence is a better way to
protect freedom than the Communist
Manifesto just just obviously true that
number drops to fifty seven percent of
Millennials why why are these numbers so
low part of it is indoctrination K
through 12 and then into college and so
many Millennials are going to college
getting saddled with debt in most cases
for no reason whatsoever and they're
being indoctrinated into hating their
own country and to unlearning their own
history and is I study the
Intercollegiate Studies Institute found
that then this was an older study from
2007 found that eight elite colleges in
the country graduating seniors knew less
about their government and their history
and their politics than incoming
freshmen they were actually becoming
more ignorant during college so part of
its indoctrination part of it is the
ignorance comes from the fact that these
Millennials and Gen Z have never
witnessed the historical problems I was
in the womb when the Berlin Wall fell
down and I'm a millennial Jens II they
mostly don't remember 9/11 I mean they
just haven't seen certainly they haven't
seen the historical problems of
communism we defeated communism before
they came of age so they just didn't see
it and naturally it's not going to be at
the top of their mind those are two
reasons and we can blame that on the
left and we can blame that on
specifically a failure of Education to
teach people their own history and to
teach people their own civics and
political philosophy the third problem
is the tougher one to grapple with which
is the failures of
modernity okay and conservatives if we
want to address this challenge we need
to be able to see reality for what it is
there are many many failings of
modernity there are many many failings
of what we would call the kind of
capitalism of the 1980s it's still a
hell of a lot better than socialism I
mean I'm not saying we need to go over
to aoc she's got all the wrong answers
Bernie Sanders got all the wrong answers
but there have been problems caused by a
very specific type of political
philosophy and economic philosophy that
we've embraced more or less as a
consensus what do I mean by that we're
told we're told that we've never had it
so good
GDP is so high unemployment is so low
everything is great where riches can be
that's all true right that those are the
facts however anxiety stress depression
suicidality are all through the roof
they are surging among teenagers suicide
is up 70 percent in recent years and we
have to grapple with that reality
something is not quite right now what
the left and the Socialists and aoc
would say is see our economic system is
hopelessly rotten and we've got our
overhaul it and steal everybody's wealth
and then that will make us all happier
of course that's not going to make us
happy at all money money can't buy
happiness which is a lesson that the
left and the socialists haven't learned
but also money can't buy happiness and
so the the problem of our politics and
our culture is very likely not exactly
economic if everything's so good if
we've never had it so that it's any
better than this then why are we so
anxious why recess stress why are we so
depressed why are we suicidal in many
cases why or antidepressant drugs so
prescribed why are we lonelier than ever
why are we so reports of loneliness or
through the roof this is a cultural
problem that the right has failed to
address in large part I think because we
so prioritize the hyper individualism
that was used successfully to defeat
Soviet Communism
why are we so lonely I'll give you I'll
give you one example in 1950 do you know
what the median age was for getting
married in 1950 the median age to get
married for a man twenty-two years old
that was when you could expect to get
married in 1950 if you were a man if you
were a woman 20 years old pretty young
by today's standards in 2010 the median
age to get married for a man 28 years
old the median age to get married for a
woman 26 years old we are delaying
maturity we are living alone a lot
longer and the numbers can't just be
accounted for with something simple like
college attendance rates they partake in
real political and cultural problems
that the right is debating right now
we'll get to that in a second first I've
got to thank our friends at Boland
branch because I am not single I am
married I share a bed with my wife and I
want to make sure that my little honey
has the finest sheets in the world
everything bow and branch makes from
bedding to blankets is made from pure
100% organic cotton that means that they
start out super soft and they get even
softer over time buying directly from
them no middleman you are essentially
paying wholesale prices you know sweet
little ELISA and my wife is pretty
easygoing she puts up with me you know
pretty well takes very good care of me
the one place that she likes to be fancy
is on hotels me I could sleep at some
rat-infested you know cockroach ridden
place off the side of the highway
sweet little ELISA has very fine taste
in hotels so I love that I can give her
five-star hotel quality sheets on our
own bed
especially because I don't have to pay
that much for them I learned luxury
sheets can cost up to a thousand dollars
in the store Boleyn branch sheets are
only a couple hundred bucks how is that
possible because they cut out that
middleman everyone who tries Boleyn
branch sheets loves them most
importantly sweet little ELISA and I
that's why they have thousands of
five-star reviews I really love them
they just feel different I mean I've
slept on cheap sheets for most of my
life I thought there was no difference
at all I was dead wrong they just feel
great and if you spend the average
person spends a third of
life sleeping if you're me it's like
closer to two-thirds of your life treat
yourself come on
shipping is free you can try them for 30
nights if you don't love them send it
back for a refund
you're not gonna want to send them back
no risk no reason not to give them a try
to get started right now I'm gonna give
you a little gift this is my gift to you
to help solve the loneliness crisis in
America to make sure that you can try to
come together and have a good
respectable life on good nice sheets 50
bucks off your first set of sheets
that's what I'm giving you
at Boland branch com promoted Michael mi
CH AE L Boland branch comm for $50 off
your first set of sheets Bo LL and
branch comm promo code Michael mi CH AE
L Boland branch comm promo code Michael
so people even as things materially are
so great are anxious stressed depressed
lonely they're not getting married
they're staying single longer and when
you ask people why they're not getting
married whether it's on a survey or just
anecdotally because I talk to a lot of
young people especially on college
campuses they'll tell you the reason
they're not getting married is they're
saddled with debt they've been funneled
into college you know in nineteen forty
I think was about 5% of Americans
graduated from a four-year college now
60% of high school graduates anticipate
expect to go to a four-year college many
of them are not going to graduate but
that's a huge increase to all of those
people need to go and get a liberal
education no they don't really need to
do that for many of them they won't get
a liberal education anyway they'll get
saddled with $200,000 in debt
they'll put themselves in a much worse
position than they could be and they'll
get indoctrinated in leftism so they'll
say well we're in debt I want to pay off
my debt before I get married other
people will say that they don't want to
get married just yet because they were
raised without a vision of a
transcendent moral order and I'm not
throwing any stones here I mean we all
grew up in this kind of environment and
so you grew up and you say why would I
get married when I can just hook up all
the time and go to bars and be single
and have fun and do whatever I want and
not be accountable to anybody the secret
of this is marriage is much more
satisfying and gratifying but you it's
you can't tell somebody this you just
have to experience it before you believe
it I know that because people told me
that and I didn't
either but it that's the secret I mean
that's the dirty little trick of the
temptation of staying single and just
satisfying your own desires and
appetites and not being accountable but
for a whole generation or now two
generations that was raised without any
real solid sense of a moral order
they're just not gonna feel any
compulsion to do it people want to
pursue their own interests that's the
mimimi society that we're living in
particularly exacerbated by social media
and the fact that we're all the little
celebrity in our own heads this is a
consequence not just of leftism okay and
the right needs to grapple with that
this is a consequence of a hyper
individualism unbridled from any moral
order this is a consequence of a lying
with people who don't share our values
though they might be good partners to
attack the Soviet Union with okay we
need to grapple of that what is the
effect of this hyper individualism
removed from the transcendent moral
order what is the effective of the
so-called fiscal conservative social
liberal meaning libertarian
individualist on economic issues and
derelict on social issues something that
I refer to as greedy leftism greedy
Democrats one effect of that is right
now in cities around the country and I
think especially in Los Angeles some
young people are paying $800 a month to
live in cages Cait cages I'm not joking
about that this is so dystopian but it's
real and there's actually a silver
lining to this story but in any case
we'll get to that after in any case
people are paying $800 a month to live
in what amounts basically to cages to
pods in a response to a political
consensus that no longer makes much
sense there is a community for young
people in cities across the country now
called upstart it's for young artists
and people who aren't making a whole lot
of money who need affordable places to
live now what people used to do is you
know go in with some friends and live in
in apartments with a lot of roommates I
did this in New York my two very good
buddies of mine and I lived in this very
tiny apartment I think my bedroom was
about 70 square feet with no windows and
one one wall was fake but you know at
least they were kind of pals of mine and
we were just all decided to go live
together now what people are doing is
they're just renting their own
individual pods like you do climb up
into a little box and that's where you
sleep each room contains up to six
capsules which the people who live there
describe as cozy I think that's probably
a euphemism and it's a single bed a bar
for hanging clothes a few compartments
for shoes and other items and an air
vent and it's still you're still paying
about $800 a month for this is that the
vision of life that we want to live in
no I mean that is a dystopian horror
movie version of what a hyper
individualistic isolating society is
going to look like where you all just
pay a lot of money and you climb up and
you live in your pod and you check into
your pod at night like you're a kind of
bug or an animal or something then you
get out and go work for the man again
tomorrow now there's a silver lining
here and this also tells us something
about the political problem upstart has
the good central location modern
building and it's got a gym and a dance
classes and a recording studio and an
arts workshop and planing in laundry
and one of the rules here is that men
and women have to sleep apart and
they're not allowed to get frisky with
one another no getting handsy after dark
in the pods one description of this is
that on taco night you get 50 people who
all live in these little individual pods
and they'll come together in one of the
four building complexes communal areas
so the downside of it is you've got this
hyper individualistic kind of dystopian
lifestyle but then the upside is trying
to reclaim a sense of normality or a
sense of a normal order in all of this
so people coming together in one sense
you're living as isolated as you
possibly could be in another you've got
fifth
the sort of roommates that maybe you can
make friends with in the one sense
you're extracting yourself from all of
your humanity on the other you're trying
to regain some kind of traditional moral
rules because you're not allowed to get
frisky in the pods you're not allowed to
completely become an animal it's a very
schizophrenic way of living that is
something that I think of you as 2,000
people on the street 999 of them would
say people shouldn't live like that
people even if you're living in
Manhattan and your apartments or maybe
indistinguishable from that pod at least
there you've got your own apartment
people should have their own apartment
their own house their own space they
should not live like their animals or
like their robots and this hyper
individualistic all that matters is
squeezing pinching every single penny no
connections to family no connections to
community we're just in our own little
pods that's not a way that people want
to live and a conservative a
conservatism that is going to make sense
in the future is going to be one that
addresses that very legitimate problem
the worst product of this political
confusion of our times
is what we would call identity politics
okay and I want to be really specific
about that term because in a certain
sense all politics is identity politics
in the sense that politics is about you
and me living together in a community
that's Paulo
politics comes from the polis the
city-state we're all just trying to live
together now this this kind of works
well when identity is rooted in unity
when when identity is rooted in subjects
of real significance in shared culture
and customs and love of country and
ultimately in God this kind of system
becomes absolutely barbaric when the
identity politics is rooted in
difference which is really what we mean
by identity politics when it becomes a
brutal battle of interests not a
reasonable exchange of ideas and a
decision of how to live together in a
community that system creates discord
when identity is viewed merely through
differences and the left is gone in this
direction for a very long time
for about a century first they wanted to
divide people on class then it was about
race and sex the right has flirted with
this as well and it's always ugly and
it's always very stupid no where has
this been better exemplified than in
Elizabeth Warren latest campaign
endorsement announcement from a group
called black woman for black it's I
guess it's black women for but it's
women spelled with an X instead of an e
so I guess it's brands will look some we
will get to that endorsement in just a
second we will get to her silly response
to that endorsement we will get to this
kind of mindless politics and maybe try
to plot a way out of it we will get to
an orangutan who has been declared a
person in Florida only in Florida folks
and we will get to death row inmate
Rodney Reed who some people are
defending because they have no sense of
justice we'll get to all of them and
even a little update from the war on
Christmas but first I've got a second by
to our friends at Facebook and YouTube
head on over to daily wired.com ten
bucks a month $100 for an annual
membership you get me you get the end or
Clavin show you get the Ben Shapiro show
you get the Matt Walsh show you'd ask
questions and the mailbag coming up on
Thursday you test questions backstage
you get another Kingdom the third and
final and best season and you get the
leftist tears tumblr mmm that's very
very delicious there's nothing divisive
about it
that is just the sheer harmony and unity
of a love of country that you can really
taste best through leftist to yours go
to daily wire.com we'll be right back
with a lot more
alright the race for president is over
folks
Liz Warren she's won it she hasn't just
won the nomination she's won the whole
presidency Trump can pack his bags and
she can start measuring the drapes
because Liz Warren has received the
endorsement of what she describes as the
backbone of our democracy a group with
three thousand Twitter followers called
black woman s'en for here is their
announcement
despite pervasive attacks on our
communities our identities and our lives
slap trans and cysts women's fans gender
non-conforming and non-binary vote
remains at the forefront of each and
every social movement to hold this
country accountable we are progressive
black leaders who are not impressed by
political theater we know that big
things happen when black women come
together and take our own space in the
political process and though no one
person could hold all our aspirations
and the hopes for president there is one
leader who we believe will work with it
hold on it was before before we go on
and finish was that last person in a
hostage video the way at least the first
couple performances all although
absolutely absurd ridiculous identity
politics at least they seem sort of
enthusiastic that third one looked like
she was being held hostage obviously
reading from a script' we believe that
the most inspiring
beep-boop beep-boop so the endorsement
goes on to explain why Liz Warren is the
choice candidate is senator Elizabeth
Warren she has a track record of taking
on the predatory policies that harm our
communities we've come together as a
elective voice and we hope to encourage
others especially black women and gender
non-conforming folks to join us we are
all in for warmth and if you are to go
to black women for zorg sign the
endorsement statement and join us there
it is there it is the elections over who
are the black women the women it's just
a Twitter account just as 3,000
followers it's not a lot of followers in
terms of political accounts but in the
age of identity politics this group has
the absolute audacity to pretend to
speak for all black women and some black
men because they're saying trans women
which is really just men and gender
non-conforming people whatever that
means so when you add all those people
together by a conservative estimate
you're talking about 19 million
Americans and you've got a Twitter
account of 3,000 people claiming to
speak for them black women and Elizabeth
Warren was happy to take it and go along
with the pretense
by the way Elizabeth Warren has very
very little black support when you just
look at the polling numbers she's not
doing that well she's not as bad as
Bernie but Joe Biden has much much
higher levels of black support so
Elizabeth Warren goes to this one
identity politics group and they say oh
no the black women actually were for
Elizabeth Warren and she plays along
with it because it's politically
advantageous to her Elizabeth Warren
tweeted out quote Thank You black women
for black trans and cysts women gender
non-conforming and non-binary people are
the backbone of our democracy and I
don't take this endorsement lightly I'm
committed to fighting alongside you for
the big structural change our country
needs black trans and sis women gender
non-conforming and non-binary people or
the backbone of our democracy you might
be surprised to hear that if you are a
Hispanic woman you're not the backbone
of our democracy according to Elizabeth
Warren Hispanic women nope sorry don't I
put a what today they're less important
to our democracy then black trans and
sis women gender non-conforming
non-binary people according to Elizabeth
Warren obviously white people much less
important Native American people less
important black men according to
Elizabeth Warren less important to our
democracy than black trans and sis women
gender non-conforming and non-binary
people now does the Elizabeth Warren
really think this no because if she
thought that she wouldn't be running for
president she would instead vote for a
black trans versus woman gender
non-conforming or non-binary people but
identity politics makes people lose
their mind especially on the left but on
the right wing to makes people lose
their mind and say very silly and stupid
things such as this if Elizabeth Horne
really believed this the most important
people to our democracy were black women
she would drop out of the race and vote
for Kamala Harris she obviously doesn't
think that because obviously one's skin
color is not the most important aspect
of their identity far from it
the one's competency to be President of
the United States is not determined by
skin color and Elizabeth Warren knows
that even though she says she has high
cheekbones and is therefore likely
Native American I mean she's been
playing this woman's from playing the
most absurd side of identity politics
her entire life this kind of mindless
politics racial politics especially is
making us all very stupid and it's
making us all very vacuous what it is
doing is removing the contemplative and
a reasonable aspect from politics and it
is just leaving us with interests and
sentiment just basically brutal people
clubbing each other over the heads with
their own irreconcilable interests and
Gus seeing it all up with sentiment
saccharine sentimentality like the
backbone of our democracy I mean I
guarantee you if a Twitter group called
Hispanic women for endorsed Elizabeth
Warren she would say that they were the
backbone of the democracy it's just so
petty it's such pandering it leaves you
with a politics that is incoherent and
inhuman and speaking of an inhuman
politics you see this taking shape
especially
down in Florida in Florida a an
orangutan named Sandra has now been
declared a nonhuman person by a by a
judge how can you be a nonhuman person
isn't that a contradiction in terms I
certainly would have thought so but
nevertheless the orangutan is a person
this is according to judge Elena
Liberatore oh gosh and it's an Italian
to talk about identity politics that I
want to disavow and remove myself from
this was a ruling based in 2015 that
declared the Sandra the orangutan is not
legally an animal but rather a non-human
person entitled to some legal rights
enjoyed by people in some better living
conditions how on earth did this maniac
judge come up with this ruling she
explains quote with that ruling I wanted
to tell society something new she didn't
want to follow the law or anything no no
that's not what you wanted to do she's a
judge after all she just wanted to tell
society something new quote that animals
are sentient beings and that the first
right they have is our obligation to
respect them I think maybe we need to
certainly focus on the care of this
Sandra the orangutan maybe we need to
get better care for this judge too she
seems to be in dire need of some extra
care so the orangutan remained at the
zoo because they're not going to buy her
house and then the zoo closed in 2016
and now Sandra the orangutan is in
Florida said another care facility this
is madness but it comes from an identity
politics that doesn't understand our own
identity we are not primarily to be
identified by nad characteristics
including the color of our skin or our
profession or our socioeconomic status
that is not our primary identity and a
normal culture knows this the culture
our culture was crafted by Christianity
our civilization was crafted by
Christianity and an understanding of God
in the Old Testament you see when Moses
asks God who are you who shall I tell
the Israelites that you are and God says
I am that I am God is the essence of
being Christ says before Abraham was I
am God describes himself as being itself
when an individual or a community or a
whole culture and civilization grounds
their identity in the ultimate identity
in God himself that culture that person
that civilization will see the world a
little more clearly will be able to live
in greater harmony will understand
himself and reality much much better
when society severs that understanding
of the ultimate identity in God when
that society loses the understanding of
I am that I am then that society is left
with a pathetic question which is Who am
I like a little child like a little
flower
hippie child whose leaves home and says
I'm just gonna go find myself and does a
bunch of drugs or something it's a
pathetic question and then you ground
your identity in ultimately unsatisfying
physical things including skin colour or
sex or sexual preferences or the amount
of money that you have or the job that
you have or the neighborhood that you
live in or your socioeconomic status or
the size of your house that will all be
unsatisfying politics grounded on those
things will not be the kind of culture
that we want to live in I mean that will
be the opposite of a heavenly politics
of politics that grounds our identity in
God that will be a hellish politics and
you see it all around us and in fact the
the nearest bit of Hope I have on this
is bizarrely in the questions being
raised by the transgender movement I've
long predicted the transgenderism would
cause a lot of headaches for the left
because it pits so many of leftist ideas
against one another it pits feminism
against gender theory it pits feminism
the idea that women are women there is
such a category as women and they get to
define womanhood for themselves against
gender theory which tells men that if
they slap some lipstick on
we're address them they really are a
woman that doesn't make a whole lot of
sense together what transgender ideology
begins to ask is actually about the
nature of the soul right how I can look
like a man but secretly be a woman
because of some immaterial metaphysical
soul is really what they're trying to
say but they can't bring themselves to
say it now of course it's not possible
for your soul in your body to be totally
opposed to one another it's not possible
for for us to live in a society that
says that our physical selves have
nothing to do with who we really are I
mean that's actually that was an idea
that was tried a thousand years ago
called alba jensen ism and we rejected
it because it's completely lunatic but
at least they're asking those questions
that are shaking us out of this stale
scientific materialist secular
individualistic use whatever terms you
want
that's stale political consensus that
have obviously left people unsatisfied
some good news on this front actually we
can see it in the war on Christmas there
is a war on Christmas we'll get into it
as the season gets a little closer
there's also a war on Advent which is
waged by the people who were actually
fighting the war on Christmas it gets
very complicated and murky but what I
will tell you is there was this whole
slew of marketing materials that came in
over the past 15 years really past 20
years which was renaming Christmas trees
into holiday trees which was taking the
word Christmas out of television
commercials and out of department stores
and off of coffee cups like the
Starbucks cup lost any imagery that
could be associated with Christmas and
just became a regular boring lame
clinical red cup and now that is
changing you're seeing Christmas come
back in you're seeing at least the new
Starbucks cup says merry coffee kind of
annoying but you know that's fine as far
as I'm concerned until Simeon is
depicted on the coffee cup proclaiming
the note de Matisse before the baby
Jesus then we still have a lot of work
to do in the war on Christmas but
nevertheless I'll take the victories
that we can get there the culture is
calling for something more specific the
culture is calling for something more
real more tangible not just this
clinical and isolating lowest common
denominator materialism or secularism
that's just unsafe
to people it's leaving people depressed
anxious living in little pods all by
themselves single not getting married
and and that that's not going to be able
to last and the left all the left is
offering is just another modernist
solution it's just silly
versions of Marxism and identity
politics some people on the right one it
basically embraced those ideas I don't
think that's going to do very much for
us I think what we need to do is is
reclaim our culture and the way you
reclaim the culture is you reclaim the
foundation of that culture which is
obviously related to cult which is in
the ultimate identity politics I am that
I am God himself before we get to that
but rather before we're able to
completely fix the culture we should
also mention a little something about
justice there is a big story related to
criminal justice that is about the death
row inmate Rodney Reed many pop culture
stars are trying to get this death row
inmate sprung from the slammer this
includes Rihanna and Kim Kardashian who
I suspect at this point has an office in
the West Wing is that I have to assume
she she seems to have so much influence
when it comes to criminal justice reform
in this administration so they're trying
to get this guy sprung from the slammer
and they say he was wrongly convicted
and there are so many questions about
his guilt there aren't really there just
aren't Rodney Reed was convicted of the
1996 rape and murder of 19 year old
Stacey Stites this was due in large part
to overwhelming DNA evidence showing him
were suggesting that he is guilty he's
set to be executed by the state in less
than two weeks on November 20th Reed
says he's the victim of racism Rita's is
black he says he's the victim of racial
bias he claims he did not murder States
but was having a secret consensual
affair with the then teenager and when
her fiancé Jimmy fennel who's a white
police officer found out he killed his
fiancee and framed this man read the
evidence determined that Stites was
raped in
many different ways and was also
strangled to death
DNA from this teenagers private parts
matches the DNA of Reed Rodney Reed his
DNA was found everywhere that it would
be found initially Reed denied even
knowing the teenager when investigators
asked him about this he said I didn't
know her never met her never talked to
her had no idea who she is the only
thing I know is what I saw on TV then he
changed his tune when they found his DNA
and said he had an affair with her but
it was consensual this was first matched
up against other biological things that
he left behind in a woman with an
intellectual disability a woman named
Caroline Rivas admitted to her
caseworker that Reid whom she had been
dating had also raped her Reid was also
connected to the rapes of five other
females according to court documents
including a twelve-year-old girl now
stites's fiance at the time of the
murder also doesn't seem like a terribly
nice fella he went to prison and was
released in 2018 after serving 10 years
for kidnapping and alleged rape of a
person in custody when he was a police
officer in 2007 and Arthur's snow an
inmate and one of the leaders of the
Aryan Brotherhood gang at the prison
that fennel was serving at signed an
affidavit saying that fennel had bragged
to him about killing Stites I don't know
if this is true either nobody seems like
a terribly nice guy in this whole
situation now of course am i inclined to
believe the leader of an the Aryan
Brotherhood and not especially
so the Innocence Project which tries to
spring convicted death row inmates from
the slammer is saying that a former
sheriff's deputy also claimed that
fennel was glad that his his wife or his
fiance was murdered stites's family the
the family of the victim believes that
Rodney Reed killed her this is not to
say that we should dismiss claims of
racial bias out of hand certainly we
shouldn't we should look into them this
is not to say that there aren't problems
in the criminal justice
system there are we should investigate
them any reasonable look at the evidence
in this case makes this guy look guilty
as sin beyond a reasonable doubt and a
system of justice must exact justice but
we're unwilling to do that we're willing
to give personhood rights to orangutans
in Florida but not personhood rights to
little babies who are being born we are
going to do as much as we can Rihanna
and and Kim Kardashian are going to do
as much as they can to spring this man
Rodney Reed who's been connected to
multiple rapes from the slammer and yet
they would I don't know about kardashian
or Rihanna personally but the left would
support the murder of a million babies a
year they clamor for it they want
taxpayers to pay for it that is there's
a real irony I mean the people who say
that we're living in a rape culture are
the same people who are saying we need
to free this this rapist Rodney Reed
from prison this is the toxicity of
identity politics that is only going to
view this case through the lens of race
rather than through the lens of evidence
of an identity politics that won't even
acknowledge the existence of babies but
will acknowledge through sentiment and
saccharine and no sort of evidence they
will try to pretend that an orangutan is
he is a human being or a person who's
not a human being whatever that means
that is incoherent that is brutal that
is depressing that is isolating that's
not the sort of politics that we want
and the way that we're going to reclaim
a coherent politics is not to bang even
louder for less reasonable frivolous
identity shallow identity as a basis of
politics it's going to ultimately root
our politics in the ultimate identity
the divine logic of the universe it will
make our politics far more reasonable
that's our show I'm Michael no this is
the Michael an old show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director Pavel why
douse key edited by Danny D'Amico audio
is mixed by Mike core Amina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera and our
production assistant is NIC Sheehan the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]